hello everyone and welcome to the only
decisive game from round 11 of this
year's data steel Masters Edition it is
pregnant versus and both of them uh had
a pretty great start at the tournament
but out of the last three games both of
them lost two games and got one draw so
uh really both of them want to get back
into this tournament by uh winning the
game and that's why this game is a
really really a nice attacking game and
um well it's the only game that did not
end in a draw from round 11 I already
said too much but um you know that's why
we are covering it so let's dive
straight into it as uh well very early
on uh we will have a completely new
territory to explore so Prague with the
white pieces opens with E4 we have fun
to see five uh Parham goes for the
Sicilian Defense Knight to F3 we have D6
and now Pawn to D4 striking in the
center sea captains Knight captures
Knight to F6 Knight the C3 and the A6
Barham goes for 49er of Sicilian and the
progos for H3 this is the atoms attack
you are preparing G4 and then G5 so here
we have a counter in the center Ponte E5
and now already uh Prague shows that he
prepared something special because
Knights the E2 is the most played move
here the Knight the B3
is the second most popular retreat but
Prague goes back Knight to F3 and now
look at this queen to C7 and now Knight
to H2 and it is now as of move eight
that we have or rather yeah as a movie
that we have a completely new game
Knight B to D7 uh another move with the
Knight for prog Knights the G4 and now
Pawn to B5 Parham says all right you
keep horsing around I'm just gonna
develop my pieces and now even Knight
the E3 we've already played 10 moves and
Prague spent six moves moving the Knight
but in return he has a knight on E3
which is a spectacular Square for this
Knight if one of the knights comes to D5
uh one uh at least one Knight is staying
there so here are Knights the B6
uh of course Parham wants to keep an eye
on the D5 Square as well and the A3 now
stopping B4 uh with Bishop to E7 and now
Bishop to D3 uh we have Bishop to E6
just continuing development nicely and
queen to F3 we have G6 and here uh
Parham Castle uh sorry the first
broadcast now Knight F to D7 uh also
preparing to Castle and preparing to
execute F5 we have D Bishop to D2 and
now Knight to C5 putting pressure on the
bishop here so Prague prefers to keep
the bishop pair and now Parham castles
and uh he might have some ideas of
bringing the other Rook into the game at
some point D5 is the move you want to
play yeah but white really made an
effort preventing that pawn from being
pushed to D5 and the other one is of
course the standard F5 breakthrough so
here Prague stops this he plays Knight
to F5 which is a peace sacrifice but not
really
uh there are two ways you could accept
this you could play uh Bishop captures
on F5 you could play G captures on F5
sort of accepted the the sacrifice or
ignore white completely uh Parham played
Bishop captures on F5 but the problem is
with G captures and F5 and E captures
you don't have time to save your Bishop
otherwise F6 will be deadly so you have
to play King to each eight get the king
out of the uh G file and now uh after
you remove the knight from the defense
of the bishop not let the Knight c37 now
you capture and now you go Queen to G4
you put pressure on the pawn and it
looks like you've completely destroyed
Black's defenses uh but after moves like
Rook to F6 guarding these six pawn and
this road coming to G8 uh black will
have a very nice counter-attacking
chances here so uh well it is possible
to do it Barham decides to go for Bishop
captures on F5 and okay uh e captures an
F5 and now Pawn to D5 now it's possible
so Parham gets the full Center and the
problem is you don't have time for F6
because of E4 and the White Queen cannot
keep fun defending the F6 Pawn so here
progo's Bishop to H6 attacks The Rook
here just Rook F to d8 we have Rook 8 to
D1 and now Pawn to e for attacking the
queen and opening up this diagonal Queen
to G4 and now Knight seat the A and
Knight C to A4 going after this Knight
he says you don't have any threats on
the king side I'm just gonna attack you
where you are weak so okay Knight
captures an A4 Knight captures and now F
captures on G6 with h captors on G6 and
now uh Prague has to be very careful
here and slow things down he has to play
a move like Rook to B1 defend his B2
pawn and the game just continues the
problem is uh Parham does not have time
to claim the C2 Pawn if he does this
then uh once the The Rook attacks the
queen uh it's uh not all the great now
both the queen and the Knight are so far
away from the King side it's very easy
to attack at H4 H5 and you bust open uh
the the king's defenses however Prague
rushed it a little bit he played Ponte
F4 and here a thing really start to go
wrong for Prague because uh well it's
just very very easy to find natural
moves for black queen to B6 would check
King to H1 and now Pawn to F5 the queen
B6 check was used to defend the G6 spawn
so you can advance the pawn to F5 now
it's possible that Prague missed this
idea
because now as you'll see he will be
struggling to find moves Queen to G3 now
Knight captures on B2 wins material Rook
to B1 and now Knight the C4 an excellent
Square for the Knight we have Ponte 4 by
Prague and King to H7 so now the queen
can move you don't have to worry about
the the G6 pawn and uh here a fine move
for Prague would have been Bishop to G5
it would pose some problems for yeah for
Parham but even with this it's not that
difficult to defend for example Rook at
the C8 and you really don't have all
that much to worry about if you go for
some Queen H4 King to G8 action even
Queen to H6 is not a problem now you
might be having some ideas of maybe HK a
capture say captors to Rook captures
Queen captures then you pick up the pawn
on G6 and then you are at least you know
you have at least a draw uh but that's
not happening for example Rook the C7
and now if he captures then just Rook
here traps the queen so uh whatever you
play it's just not enough but Bishop to
G5 would definitely be the the best
attempt for white so here instead prog
played Bishop captures on C4 but now
King captures an H6 Prague goes back
Bishop to B3 now Rook 8 to C8 with eight
characters a captures and now Rook after
D1 uh Pawn to D4 and parham's massive
Center continues marching forward the
queen to F2 stops the advancement of the
d-pawn as the queen would hang on B6 so
Rook the C3
and now Rook to A1 uh product trying to
take advantage of the open a file but
now Queen to F6 uh putting uh pressure
on this diagonal preparing Queen to H4
to trade Queens uh Rook the A7 proc does
get his Rook to the seventh rank but
just Queen to H4 here Prague of course
declines the trade Queen to F1 uh and
now we have Pawn to D3 now it's possible
as Prague is pretty much without a move
you can't capture the bishop would hang
so G3 attacking the queen and now just D
captures on C2 uh Parham calculates
everything precisely because if you
capture the queen dangerous root
characters on D1 now you have to trade
the queen for rokro captures C capture
Sunday one bringing another Queen Bishop
characters and now you can play pretty
much anything like Bishop captures and
H4 you are up uh two pawns this will be
completely winning for you uh but
instead we have Rook captures on d8 by
Prague and now uh Parham just plays
Bishop capture San Diego now this is not
the this is not an optimal response
probably because it's moved 38 so he's
trying to reach time control I do not
have the exact time that he had on this
move but I will just show that C1 is
resigns on the spot I mean you bring
another queen into the game and that's
it there's there's no move that you can
play here
uh even if you go for something like
Rook to h8 with check trying to pick up
the queen here or something like that I
mean there's always the other Queen
whatever you do you're gonna be down a
queen like King to G7 Queen captures and
C1 you're gonna play real characters on
C1 with check King G2 Rook a queen
captures an h8 and there's just nothing
you are up a full Queen so it's very
weird that that Parham did not play Pawn
to C1 uh he played Bishop capture 78
it's probably because he already
calculated that he's just gonna be up to
Pawns in a completely winning end game
uh so he just he just stopped
calculating but yeah he he is correct G
captures an H on H4 now C1 Queen uh you
have to trade Queen capture through
captures with checking the G2 and now
Bishop captures and H4 you're up to
pawns and uh you are completely winning
but as usual Prague makes it very very
difficult for him to actually win this
he plays Rook the A6 now preparing
Bishop to F7 to go after the G6 pawn and
you if you can gobble up this pawn and
open up the black King things might
might be okay so here Rook to C3 attacks
the bishop Bishop to E6 first now
preparing captures on
uh on on F5 because Rook to G3 check was
also an option so Rook to C2 uh this
delivers checking to H1 and now Bishop
to F6 stopping Bishop captures and F5
even though you could play it but uh
Prague decides to go after the B5 Pawn
now he's attacking the bishop ended the
B5 pawn and he will win this Pawn uh
King to G7 defends the bishop now Bishop
captures on B5 and now Parham is only up
one Pawn the problem is his prox King is
completely cut off from the game uh we
have Rook Dev to now going after the the
F4 Pawn uh Rook the A7 with check with
King to H6 now Rook the A6 goes after
the bishop uh Bishop to D4 and now uh
Bishop to E8 goes after the G6 pawn and
you can't really defend this Pawn we
have quanta E3 Rook capture Sun G6 now
it's two pawns each uh Parham is no
longer up material King to H7 and now
Rook to G1 getting ready to counter that
pawn on the E1 Square point the E2 now
preparing Rook to F1 and now Bishop to
B5 stopping the immediate thread of Rook
to F1 as the uh the bishop is covering
that and now the problem for uh Parham
is that there is only one winning move
in The Possession uh but luckily you
guys are here to to help him win this uh
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the only winning move uh while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
instant brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Rook the H2 with check I had to do it in
slow motion but there are only two
squares I mean it's impossible so Rook
to HD check and it was in this position
on move 52 that pregnant resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here it's a it's a forced line so
congratulations to everyone who spotted
this uh because now after King Cactus
and H2 You're Gonna Play Bishop captures
and G1 with check and after King
captures just E1 queen queen against
Bishop of course you resigned this so uh
proxotis after Rook Dage to check he
resigned and uh a wonderful uh victory
for for Parham maxulu breaking his
losing streak like I said out of the of
the previous three games he got two
losses and a draw and uh Prague
continues his losing streak as now even
though he had a spectacular start of the
tournament out of the last four games he
now lost three games and um I got one
draw so not not the best uh but still a
few games left in the tournament we'll
see what happens nothing really changed
here regarding the standings as all the
other games sended in a draw uh so I
think Parham is um currently in eighth
place and Prague not doing all that the
great uh but I will check for you I
don't wanna I don't want to trick you
guys uh yeah currently it's um okay
probably Ninth Place yeah because he he
had such a great start of the tournament
even the the three losses now uh still
keep him in Ninth Place yeah I saw very
nicely done yeah not not much else
changed uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it Prague tried to
break the the losing streak he went for
a very exciting line like we've shown I
mean from the from the first 10 moves uh
this is what it means uh don't bring
don't break the opening principles but
if you are a very strong Grandmaster
like uh Prague hero former 2700 uh you
can break it you know they say don't
move the same same piece twice in the
opening Prague move that six times
um out of the first 10 moves so if
you're if you're that strong you can
play and he had a fine position but he
he just over pushed it a little bit and
of course Parham is too strong and he
punished that
uh but yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it maybe it inspired you to
try something extra in in your own games
I would like to thank Peter Pinery uh
John Noonan Russell Scott lost him Altar
and Franz bookhold for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
steel until it finishes uh so thank you
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day